joining us now on the phone is President
Donald Trump from the White House
tonight mr. president thank you sir for
being with us well thank you very much
and how good is Mark marks on fire
tonight I there's no doubt about it fire
that's why I call him the great one I
want to start we have an election in 117
days mr. president and you know your
campaign came out with an ad the issue
of law and order and safety and security
are now key in this country will go over
Joe Biden's comments but your campaign
released this ad it's I'm of the view
that nobody pursues happiness if you're
not safe and secure let's roll with
let's roll tape you have reached the 911
police emergency line due to defunding
of the police department we're sorry but
no one is here to take your call if
you're calling to report a rape please
press 1 to report a murder
press 2 to report a home invasion press
3 for all other crimes leave your name
and number and someone will get back to
you our estimated wait time is currently
five days goodbye I'm Donald J Trump and
I approve this message
mr. president I'm gonna read the
comments of Joe Biden if I may he said
surplus military equipment for law
enforcement by the way they used it in
Ferguson and Baltimore they don't need
that the last thing you need is an
up-armored hmmwv coming into a
neighborhood I haven't noticed that it's
like a military invading they don't know
anybody they've become the enemy they're
supposed to be protecting the people
then asked about funding do you agree we
can redirect the funding absolutely okay
mr. president I would argue that no
American could be happy if they're not
safe and secure or pursue happiness
without safety and security well I agree
with that 100% and we need safety we
need security we can't defund our police
and we can't abolish uh police they want
to abolish our police and as far as the
surplus equipment I've given out
hundreds of millions of dollars this is
stuff that was sitting in storage houses
all over the country
it wasn't even old but it was never
going to be used again it was gathered
Dustin I gave it out to all of our
police forces all over the country saved
many many police lives and many lives I
think period it was really a lot of it
was protective equipment and I know that
President Obama and Biden didn't want to
give it out they thought it was terrible
to give it out it made the police look
too strong and I gave it out and I have
been thanked by every Police Department
it's the president while the Summer of
Love zone turned into a shooting zone
and I'm gonna run some videotape one is
a man shot while walking his
six-year-old little girl in the Bronx in
New York fascinated in broad daylight
another gunman opened fire and in a
Bronx apartment building then I'll show
the on this very show live our own Steve
Harrigan interviewing protesters that
took over a city block in Atlanta that
resulted in the death of an
eight-year-old girl two weeks later you
see what's happening shootings up
violent crime is up murders up you know
a hundred and thirty percent shootings
up in New York City you see the
statistics in Chicago every weekend how
do you react to that well first of all
New York City is not recognizable crime
is way up shootings their way up
murderers way up it's just unbelievable
Chicago what's going on in Chicago and
we are looking at it very seriously
because we're gonna have to do something
we've asked them you know we're really
supposed to be asked to come in and help
the federal government and we have the
greatest people in the world and we can
solve it but we're supposed to be a so
the mayor or the governor of Illinois
should be asking but they don't want to
ask and you look every weekend and every
week in Chicago it's just numbers that
are not believable Atlanta is starting
to have some problems so we're ready to
act and at some point we may have to act
anyway we have to do it sooner rather
than later let's talk about the issue of
a key I I had a source that told me I
was not able to confirm it that one of
the reasons that the Seattle mayor
finally acted is that they were given
notice that if they didn't act that you
were going to is there any truth to that
100% we were going in we were going in
very soon we
let them know that and they all of a
sudden they didn't want that so they
went in before we got there and but we
were going in very shortly very soon and
we would have taken the chop they call a
chop we would have taken it back very
easily but they went in and frankly the
people just gave up they were tired they
had it for a long period of time but
because of the fact that we were going
to go to go in now if you look at
Minneapolis after four or five days of
ära we called them we said you got to
get out the National Guard we insisted
that they do it when the National Guard
finally got out they walked through it
like a knife goes through butter that
was the end of their problem that was it
it was a great job done by the National
Guard and yeah we were all set to go
into Seattle frankly I looked forward to
it mr. president
Joe Biden was vice president for eight
years Barack Obama's hometown of Chicago
every weekend we get these statistics
Lawrence Jones who is our 2020 reporter
on this program actually interviewed the
father he lost a seven-year-old little
girl I don't know how you recover from
something like that and but this it
Biden and and Barack Obama President
Obama Vice President Biden they barely
ever talked about the violence in Barack
Obama's hometown what what specifically
can you do I know you've offered to help
New York City I know you've offered to
help Chicago I know you offered to help
Seattle I know you did help many apples
and you did help DC but when they keep
refusing your help what are your options
so first of all I saw the interview and
he's a lovely man I spoke to him at
length and with his friend who's a great
guy to houris Lorenzo Anderson yes sir
his sigh heavily invited them down to
the White House at some point when they
get you know when they get when they get
adjusted because it is so tough I mean
what he's going through is so tough and
he was treated very badly they didn't
even tell him what had happened when did
it happened very sad thing but I did
speak to him and had a you know great
but very sad converse
and so he'll be coming down when he's
ready he'll be coming down to the White
House I will say look they have to be
tough they have to be smart what's going
on there and you know the Chicago Police
is terrific too New York Police New
York's finest they're just not being
allowed to do their job they don't want
to do anything because they'll end up
they'll end up with lots of bad things
happening to him they're not letting him
do the job and I dealt a lot with mayor
de Blasio I was very nice to men de
Blasio I got him ventilators when he
needed him I got him Hospital help when
he needed it
I got him everything he needed I got him
the gowns I got him the masks I got him
everything the shields I got that man
everything I spoke to him many times he
couldn't have been nicer and then he
throws a big black lives matter Stein
right down in the middle of Fifth Avenue
and all merchants along Fifth Avenue are
furious they're furious and the whole
city is fierce the city is a city that's
in rage and it was almost a test shot
but I was so good to him and to Governor
Cuomo like nobody's ever been good and
all you end up doing out of that place
is get prosecuted and have a lot of
trouble so New York is not the place
that it was everyone's leaving they're
moving to Florida they're moving to
other places it's very sad actually to
see what happened yeah to be honest I'm
the only idiot that stays here I need to
get my contract changed so I can get the
hell out of here myself to be honest you
know in 1984 the question came up
especially after the first debate
President Reagan had at the time with
Walter Mondale the age question let me
play a montage well let's say not some
of the finest moments of Joe Biden and I
want your reaction and the question will
be does he have the mental alertness
does he have the strength and stamina
what I believe is the hardest job in the
world it's not what I do
being president I argue I would argue
about the hell of a lot harder but
here's Joe Biden
but the scale of a loss was staggering
it's been two months this kind of scored
in that mind just so much for tuning in
tomorrow's super third Tuesday and I
want to thank you all I tell you what
I'm rushing ahead on it we hold these
truths to be self-evident
all men are women created by goal you
know that you know the thing is joke
blog on the Democratic candidates for
the United States Senate
look me over you agree with me go to Joe
303 303 choose truth over facts play the
radio make sure the television the
excuse me make sure you have the record
player on at night the phone make sure
the kids hear words for kids are just as
bright and just as talons white kids
Donald Trump does pose an excellent
sense to this it's not hypothetical why
in god's name should someone who's
clipping coupons in the stock market
make in fact pay a lower tax rate than
someone who in fact is like I said a
schoolteacher and a firefighter I think
my fate my personal favorite is we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created and women are created
equal by the thing you know you know the
thing that would be God who created
everything but mr. president in your
view does he have the alertness trying
to be charitable here the strength and
stamina you're in the job I would argue
the toughest job in the in the world
that's my position I've held that for
many decades well I'm not the good CH
because I was with Bernie Marcus I think
he's 91 he's so sharp he's as sharp as
ever he's going to the founder of Home
Depot one of the founders great guy and
I deal with other people in their late
80s early 90s and they're a hundred
percent mentally so sharp sheldon Adel
said as an example and others many
others like it and they they're mentally
a hundred percent but Joe is just look
let's face it he's been taken over by
the radical left
has no clue what they're doing and what
they're getting him into this is worse
than Bernie Sanders that is at his best
and you look at the deal they made with
Bernie Sanders now in the group but it's
all crazy radical left stuff and Joe's
never going to be able to fight it even
if he disagreed with it which I actually
don't think he does I think they you
know there's an expression old
expression was used badly a long time
ago in politics I think they brainwashed
him they brainwashed him he doesn't know
where he is he doesn't know what he's
doing and our country will suffer our
stock markets will crash bad things will
happen they will defund the police they
will abolish the police it will be maybe
a backlash or maybe it'll just go to
hell like Venezuela you hear stories now
and then Thomas Friedman and the New
York Times is wanting to now create all
new conditions for Joe Biden who agreed
to debate you now he apparently says
that he has many cognitive tests he's
tested all the time cognitively maybe
they maybe he'll release those records
and maybe he'll release his medical
records everybody wants to see seemingly
see everything about you now would you
agree to any new conditions or does he
have to debate like it's always but
they'll happen and do you think he's
trying to back out and debating you well
yeah the answer is yes absolutely but
you know he met the covent test the
covetous he didn't mean cognitive he met
Covino he said cognitive I'm pretty but
he doesn't mean that because you know
you don't have those tests at office he
said I take him all the time and now he
met Kovac but I think he was confused by
the question and the words and
everything else he he didn't mean that
because he hasn't taken any cognitive
test because he couldn't pass one I
actually took one when I very recently
when I when I was you know the radical
left was saying is you all there is you
all there and I proved that was all
there because I stood I aced the test
and he should take the same exact test
the very standard test I took took it at
Walter Reed Medical Center in front of
doctors and they were very surprised
they said that's an unbelievable thing
rarely does
buddy do what you just did but he should
take that same test but no he has been
totally taken over and I think it's
because he doesn't understand what's
going on I watched him today I watched
him over the last couple of weeks and
you know I look forward to debating him
but it looks like he wants to try and
get out of the debates I think we're
doing very well in the polls I think if
you look at the different states I think
we're doing very well we're rapidly
rising I was with the president of
Mexico yesterday we had an incredible
day we have tremendous Hispanic support
we have tremendous african-american
support I think we have great support
period you look at the boats you look at
the bikers you look at everything that's
happening in our country this great
spirit spirit like nobody's ever seen
before actually and there's no spirit
for Joe let me let me ask you about the
recent rise in outbreaks and we had
talked about this all throughout the
beginning of coronavirus and that was
that dr. oz said it often on both radio
and TV with me that it's not a matter of
if it's a matter of land that there are
going to be hot spots and re-emergence
etc we're now seeing such things happen
this time in the Sun Belt Florida
Governor De Santis was on one of the
things that that that he did differently
as he went in and protected the nursing
homes and the elderly care facilities
he's doing the same and I was a little
bit surprised that the numbers in
Florida in terms of the ages of people
not oh that are contracting the virus
much much younger on the one hand you
don't want anyone to contract it but on
the other hand we know that the people
that are most vulnerable to this virus
for severe illness or death are those
that are elderly those with underlying
conditions or those with compromised
immune systems and it does not impact
young people anywhere near the way it
does older people what do you make of
these hotspots as we call them and in
Florida and Texas and other states and
dr. cauchy's comments well first of all
the mortality rate and doctor foul she's
a nice man but he's made a lot of
mistakes like you don't have to ban him
coming in from very infected China I did
it anyway we saved hundreds of thousands
of lives i banned Europe from coming in
when Italy and
France and Spain were having all the
problems that we saved hundreds of
thousands of lives a lot of people said
don't do it
they've been wrong about a lot of things
including face masks maybe they're wrong
maybe not but a lot of them said don't
wear a mask don't wear a mask and now
they're saying wear a mask so a lot of a
lot of mistakes were made a lot of
mistakes let me just make one statement
though we do testing like nobody's ever
done testing and when we test the more
you test the more cases you find other
countries you know when they test and I
asked them all they test when somebody's
not feeling well or when somebody walks
into a hospital so they don't have tests
they have tests that are very very
limited we have these massive 40 45
million people have been tested it's a
record and our tests are the best so we
have cases all over the place most of
those cases immediately get better they
get you know people they're young people
they have sniffles and two days later
they're fine and they're not sick to
sort of it they're asymptomatic a lot of
things happen and what we're doing is
with all of these tests that we're doing
all over the country tests everybody
tests pull up parking lots everything
else what we've done is we've created
tremendous number of cases everybody
else can you imagine if China tested
like we test they don't can you imagine
if other big countries the bigger
countries tested like we or Germany
we've tested many many many times even
proportionately the number of people
that other countries have tested but I
was with as an example a great gentleman
yesterday the President of Mexico and
having a hard time especially in Mexico
City they test when somebody's sicker
when somebody goes into the hospital and
that's a different way of doing it and
it's just fine and we are testing and
creating it's the greatest thing that
ever happened for the opposite party but
we're doing something that nobody's ever
done to the extent and we're doing a
great job but we have a mortality rate
think of this that's 10 fold better than
any other we what we're doing is
incredible if you look you've heard the
numbers tenfold we have fewer people
dying and our people have done an
incredible job and
another thing we're very well on the way
to a vaccine very well on the way
therapeutically therapeutics were very
well on the way we've got a lot of great
things happening we already do we do
have some that are that are very
effective or at least effective and a
lot of very good things have happened a
lot of really good things they're doing
a great job but the testing is just
showing up all these cases that have you
turned the news on you'll see it's
always the word cases they don't talk
about death because deaths are way down
they talk about cases all the time cases
and those cases get better and they in
most most cases in almost I mean
literally in most cases they
automatically cure they automatically
get better Joe Biden revealed in a
previous rare of you know well a rare
appearance out of his bunker or basement
bunker but he revealed that everybody
around him including his Secret Service
are tested every day I know having
interviewed you for example before the
Wisconsin Town Hall that we did that
dive I was I had to have a test before I
got around the president I think by the
way that's the right thing to do for
both you and Joe Biden that's my own
opinion but you're the two people that
don't need to wear a mask and there's
been a lot made over the fact that well
Donald Trump doesn't you know it doesn't
wear a mask you're the two people I
would argue that probably don't need to
wear the mask where the rest of the
public might benefit from it I saw it
anecdotally in I was at the epicenter of
this and my local grocery store there
wore masks and thank God no cashier and
knows guys stocking the shelves ever got
sick in that store and I'd ask him every
week what are your thoughts on not only
masks wearing but also do we have enough
PPE for Houston and and other hotspots
as they arise well we do and we've done
a great job in that we've created a
supply chain that's incredible on
ventilators were making thousands a week
on PPE we are doing great we do but you
know I think it's fine to wear a mask if
it makes you feel comfortable I think
under certain conditions like when
you're going into a hospital I'll be
going to Walter Reed
to see some of our great soldiers that
have been injured badly injured and also
see some of our covert workers the
people that have done such a great job
and I expect to be wearing a mask when I
go in to Walter Reed you're in a
hospital setting I think it's a very
appropriate thing I have no problem with
a mask I don't think you need one when
you're tested all the time everybody
around you is tested you're quite a
distance you know you talk about social
distancing you're away like I watched
Biden walk into a stage with his
practically like today there was almost
nobody in the room he's making a speech
and they have these massive circles and
the circles are very far away from each
other to start off with and then they
have just a few people in the audience
and he makes a speech and he walks onto
the stage wearing this massive mask
there's nobody on the stage and then he
takes it off he likes to have it hang
off usually the left ear I think it
makes them feel good frankly if you want
to know the truth and I guess that's
okay but you know when there's nobody
around you don't really have to do that
but he feels as good and I'm okay with
it if he wants to do that he's got the
largest bask I think I've ever seen it
covers up a young boy wearing a
masterwork Rick he feels he looks good
that way
I think I look I walk around with a mask
in New York and I look better I there's
no doubt about it
so you will be wearing a mask at Walter
Reed on Friday yeah I think if I'm the
right setting if I'm with the soldiers
people that you know I don't want to
spread anything it's a lot of it it's
you spreading not them spreading it's
you spreading know and I don't want to
cause a problem for anybody no I have no
problem with masks but it's got to be
done at the right time now I'm usually
fairly isolated as the president so I'm
fairly isolated everybody's tested
before they come in I wasn't allowed to
go around you until I got a test of this
no I know but it's they do a great job
they really do a great job no I have no
problem with masks just up to you let me
ask you this you know I know when you
built all of these hospitals you brought
in the Navy ship for New York you built
the hospital you you you built 3,000
beds at the Javits Center they only used
a thousand they only use like 200 on on
the Comfort but you also man those those
beds you also provided the PPE but you
also can
verted both the ship and the Javits
Center 3000 beds they only use a
thousand to cope it capability now my
understanding is you had to change the
ventilation system to actually make that
happen does that and there are reports
maybe the RNC is exploring an outdoor
venue for the convention in Jacksonville
is it are you convinced or the experts
telling you the ventilation systems need
to be up to a certain standard I'm not
an expert on it
well ship ventilation systems very much
they circularized and they're very much
under review to be honest with you but
we did a great job with the comfort we
did a great job with the mercy of the
comfort you know and in Los Angeles we
had a great ship very sister sister ship
a really terrific operation but when we
moved it in that was they didn't send us
people and then they said could you
convert it to Kovac because it wasn't
meant for that it was meant for
operations but it wasn't getting used
and so the governor asked if we could
convert it for kovat and we did and they
didn't use it and we took the Javits
Center did a phenomenal job in
record-setting time a matter of days we
converted it into a mass of like two
thousand six hundred units and they
didn't use it or very little did they
use it I said what are you doing with
all of these requests and then you're
not using it what's going on and if they
would have used that instead of nursing
homes they wouldn't have lost thousands
of people in the nursing homes they
could have put people in jabot center or
they could have put them on the ship but
they put him back in nursing homes and
they were badly infected and then they
ended up hitting the people that are
most vulnerable in thousands of people
since died now it was the worst decision
and it was made by New York Governor
Cuomo and Pennsylvania Governor wolf and
Murphy in in New Jersey and in Michigan
Governor Whitmer let me ask you about
today's Supreme Court decisions and
rulings Marc Levin was talking about it
as it relates to sort of a mixed bag of
verdicts 72 decisions and one would send
things back to the lower court but open
up the possibility of at least some of
your taxes being revealed to a
prosecutor in the Southern District of
New York
and the other saying no to Congress they
don't have a right to that information
your thoughts well first of all under
tax audit okay so I mean they treat the
IRS treats me just like they used to
treat the Tea Party except worse and I'm
under tax audit I have been for a long
period of time we made a deal a long
time ago and once I ran for politics
that deal was like we didn't make it so
I'm under a continuing audit and anybody
that did that or showed that before you
have it finalized but they treat they
treat me horribly
the IRS horribly it's a disgrace what's
happened we had a deal done in fact it
was I guess it was signed even and once
I ran or once I won or somewhere back a
long time ago everything was like well
let's start all over again it's a
disgrace so I was disappointed and and
at the same time it was because I think
we a president should get protection
from thousands of prosecutors out there
thousands all over the country they
could go after you and you're supposed
to be running the country I'll tell you
Justice Alito wrote a totally brilliant
decision he wrote something today that
really got it man Justice Thomas
likewise was was great they were the
Jews were that that came so it was look
it basically sends it all back and we
start all over again I guess that's what
it means let me ask you about some new
information we have as it relates to the
deep state as we call it we now know
that George papadopolis that exculpatory
evidence was withheld we now know in the
case of general Flynn exculpatory
evidence was withheld and I'll get
specifically into that January 5th
meeting in the White House with Barack
Obama and Joe Biden and still I mean the
judges even the even the Department of
Justice said it's time to let that case
go both parties when they say that
usually it ends it but the judge has an
emphatic clearly against general Flynn
then we have I thought we were
guaranteed the right to a fair and
impartial jury and we discovered that
the jury foreperson in the Roger stone
case
literally was speaking out publicly in
the most negative terms against Roger
personally and any Trump supporter the
judge refused to grant him a new trial
which to me is a unfathomable I would
give that right to every American if
somebody's biased on the jury that case
is out and then you have of course they
dragged out of mothballs the metaphor
tissue there's been some reports
especially about Roger stone do you have
any plans to either commute sentences or
any plans to pardon any of these men
well first of all President Obama and
Joe Biden spied on my campaign they knew
everything that was going on they were
in the rooms when everyone was talking
about it these people all work for them
I know how the White House works I guess
I can say now better than anybody and
they knew everything that was going on
they spied on my campaign I said it a
long time ago nobody believed me and now
it turns out to be fact so let's see
what happens but they were the head of
it and it was Comey and Brennan and and
everybody else clapper and those guys
all lied to Congress and bad things
happened and Stroke and page the two
lovers and many other people many other
people when you look at I couldn't I
could go down a list of lots of people
they were spying in my campaign it was
totally illegal if that were the other
way around the people would be in jail
for 50 years that would have started two
years ago it's a disgrace what's going
on we caught them a hundred percent
as far as general Flynn he's a great
hero he's a great gentleman what they're
doing to that man they've destroyed that
man but he'll come back he's going to
come back Roger stone was treated very
unfairly unbelievably unfairly and I
watched that and I thought it was
incredible the way that I was going to
jail you know there was a jury forewoman
who was it was disgraceful and the judge
the way she treated him I think it was a
disgrace that they didn't give him a
retrial Roger stone and Papadopoulos I
mean you they have a tape of his
conversation if anything he's like it
was a perfect as I said about my
conversation I turned out to be right
it was a perfect conversation that
Papadopoulos had and they destroyed him
too and put him in jail for two weeks so
these people and poor men afford what
they did to that man is is a disgrace
have you thought about pardons or
commutations at all I am always thinking
I am always thinking oh you'll be
watching like everybody else in this
case you'll be watching but Roger stone
rapid appleís man afford where they did
to that man what they did to that man
putting him in solitary confinement Al
Capone the great gangster the ultimate
gangster was never in solitary
confinement you know what they did what
they did to him was just incredible and
you know look it's a very sad thing
here's a group we have him cold they
lied they leaked they did everything we
have them already yeah we could get they
could get more evidence it doesn't
matter they have them called
I hope that they act I hope that Lindsey
Graham does something with a Judiciary
Committee we have all the evidence they
need now maybe they're getting new stuff
I let them handle that but the Judiciary
Committee should act and I like people
don't like to say it's President Obama
he knew everything he was probably in
charge of it or was in charge of it Jill
Biden you know I don't know if he knows
where he is but he was there he knew
everything well he lied Joe Biden lied
to George Stephanopoulos and he said I
know nothing but you know the notes the
notes from Peters truck were clear about
the January 5th meeting now that the
case against Flynn was to be dropped on
the jet on January the 4th struck and
and Comey bought brought it back to life
but in that meeting in the Oval Office
we know that it was Biden that said Oh
what about bringing up the the Logan Act
from 1799 we know that Obama was saying
maybe wouldn't tell the incoming
administration Obama said we want our
guys on this Sally Yates testified she
was shocked at Obama knew every aspect
of the call add to that we know that
premeditated fraud was committed on the
FISA Court we know there was Russian and
a fear ins
we
Clinton bought and paid for lying
dossier we know obstruction happened
with her with the the deleted emails and
bleach bitten hammers and we know that
there was a quid and a pro and a quote
with Joe and zero experience hunter
there's no doubt that there's a my mind
a double standard to me one of the
biggest opponents you have in 117 days
as well I call them the media mob what
is your thoughts on the media these days
because they don't seem to care about
obstruction or rushin and appearance or
quid pro quos if it's a Democrat and by
the way Christopher's here was just a
judge guilty in London or wherever on
what he said about other people with his
fake dossier his phony disgusting
dossier and he's a part of it too there
are many people that are a part of it
that you didn't even mention you don't
have enough time they've all been caught
now let's see what happens but they've
all been caught and they spied in the
campaign and you could call it treason
you could call it many different things
but it's very serious and so far
nothing's happened because that is
vicious and I guess the Republicans
they're just not vicious they're just
not it's very sad to see but we have
some great ones though I'll tell you
when you see Jim Jordan and you see
meadows and you see Devon Nunez and you
see many of them many of them leaves
Eldon and and Kevin is fantastic Kevin
McCarthy what a job he's doing we got so
we have some great ones but they're
straight players you know there's a very
straight players on the other side they
are not straight players it's a disgrace
what's happening and then you look at
what's going on in Democrat run cities
and how horrible it is and the media is
totally corrupt when I say totally
largely there are some very fine people
I know in the media some very honorable
people but largely it's corrupt not even
fake it's corrupt
no there was they never cared about the
the Russian dossier that was never never
verifiable because it was all false used
as a base of basis of a FISA warrant
you're correct that was to get a FISA
application to spy on your campaign your
transition team and in the words of the
Attorney General
bar deep into your presidency and we are
awaiting the work of prosecutor John
Durham we'll see where that goes
attorney general bar said that this is
not about a report it's a criminal
investigation but again that is beyond I
guess my paygrade I asked you a question
in Wisconsin and you got criticized for
the answer I want to ask you again
you're now asking America and 117 days
to give you a second term as president
of the United States let's what is your
second term agenda well first of all I
didn't know I was criticized for that
answer because it's a simple question
first we're going to defeat the
invisible enemy and that's that were
well on our way and as again I told you
the mortality rate is 10 fold down we're
gonna rebuild the economy we're gonna
bring back jobs from all of these
foreign lands that have stolen our jobs
or horrible trade deals we're gonna
continue to make great trade deals we're
gonna finish rebuilding our wall we're
gonna finish we're gonna have that it's
going to be almost complete by the end
of this year shortly thereafter it's
finished it's made a tremendous
difference you see we're doing record
numbers on the border very few people
are able to get through we're rebuilding
with our military we've rebuilt the
military two point five trillion dollars
we're fixing up the VA for our vets what
the job we've done there between choice
and accountability we have choice where
they have where they can go out and get
a doctor if they're sick they don't have
to wait for five weeks six weeks two
weeks so we're doing great with the vets
and the vets are loving Trump we're
protecting our Second Amendment so
important we need more judges and more
justices you see that now with the
Supreme Court more than ever and the
next president I've had two and the next
presidents going to be able to pick two
or three or one or whatever but a lot of
justices and that means everything
whether it's for life or other things I
mean it means so much but protecting the
Second Amendment
getting more judges all of the things
that we've done nobody has done what
this administration has done in the
first three and a half years nobody's
even come close when you look at every
now what we're doing is working on
lowering drug prices and knocking out
special interest because it's not easy
we're fighting for choice we did it for
the veterans now we're doing it for
school too we're one choice in school so
a parent can take their child to a
school of their choice and that's
happening very good very very well and
we have many things that we're doing and
many things that we've already completed
and you can't do more than what we've
done I think we've set records on every
we actually set a record on judges we're
going to be by the time of the end of
this year we'll be up to almost 300
federal judges and that's a record
that's incredible including DC where do
you see the economy come November 3rd
Election Day and in terms of we talk
about a v-shaped recovery we had the we
broke a record with in terms of retail
sales they expected about nine and a
half million job loss you got a two and
a half million job being followed up by
about a five million job gain yep
personally I didn't think we'd see
numbers like that till the earliest of
August where do you see the economy
where will we be with the border wall
how many miles come November 3rd ok well
first of all the the border wall is
doing incredibly well we're moving along
and we are up to about 250 miles already
we'll have by the end of the year it'll
be close to finished it might take an
extra couple of months but we'll have it
and it'll be it's it's had a huge impact
already because we're about halfway
finished the economy it's one of the
bits the thing the economy is starting
to really do great we're gonna have a
great third quarter we're gonna have a
great fourth quarter and next year is
going to be the best I think one of the
best years that we've ever had and
that's the way it looks you know this is
not about numbers have you mentioned the
2.8 and the almost 5 million those are
record numbers in history we've never
created jobs to the level that we have
now and before the China plague came in
the China virus whatever you want to
call it came in we were beating
everybody so badly including China we
were beating everybody China had the
worst
they had the tariffs I've heard them
they had the worst year they've had
we've taken in billions and billions of
dollars in tariffs at the worst year in
67 years whereas we had the best year
we've ever had and then we got hit with
the plague but now we're rebuilding it
and it's going much faster than anybody
thought possible of thee all right we
have less than a minute you work with
Kanye West and Kim Kardashian for
criminal justice reform I also put into
your executive order of police reform
but now Kanye apparently is running for
president what's your reaction well I
like his voice being heard but he's
always gonna be for us I mean he's gonna
be for us and his wife is going to be
for us but I like that he's taking off
yeah the problem is you know he's missed
some states little thing like that it's
just a few states like about 12 so you
have to do that but he's a very good guy
he is a person that I get along with
very well and in the end I think he
would support us over anyone else but
you know if he does or not look we have
to stop the radical left from taking
over our country ripping down our are
great heroes they're ripping down our
heroes when they take down those statues
and those monuments they're ripped when
they take down George Washington and
they take down Abraham Lincoln and
ulysses s grant when they take down
these people and abolitionists people
that happens think of it abolitionists
to me because I think most of them don't
even know what they're doing well dr.
alveda can we're not gonna be venezuela
i did like what dr. alveda King said in
that one she's a friend of the program
is that you know this garden of Heroes
that will represent every American from
every background mr. president we've
gone just a little long here thank you
for your time we appreciate you being
with us and 117 days to go all right
thank you very much John thank you
we're 26 days away live free or America
dies